.
CHARLIE D'AGATA, THANK YOU.
>>> WE ARE LEARNING THAT THE
PANDEMIC MAY LEAD TO PERMANENT
CHANGES IN AMERICAN LIFE.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI YESTERDAY
SUGGESTED THAT PEOPLE MAY WANT
TO CONTINUE TO WEAR MASKS
SEASONALLY TO PROTECT AGAINST
VIRUSES LIKE THE FLU AS WELL AS
COVID-19.
AS RESTRICTIONS EASE UP, SOME
ARE MAKING A COMEBACK.
AND FRIDAY WAS THE BUSIEST DAY
AT AIRPORTS IN MORE THAN A YEAR.
OUR ERROLL BARNETT IS THE IN
NEWARK LIBERTY INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT IN NEW JERSEY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
A LOT OF PEOPLE RUSHED OFF TO
SEE MOM THIS WEEKEND.
THAT'S GOOD NEWS FOR PEOPLE WHO
DEPEND ON TOURISM.
>> Reporter: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT, TONY.
GOOD MORNING.
WONDERFUL NEWS FOR THE TRAVEL
INDUSTRY, BUT BETTER NEWS IF
YOU'RE A MOTHER, WHETHER YOU'RE
AN M-O-M OR LIKE ME AN M-U-M,
THIS WAS A WONDERFUL WEEKEND
BECAUSE IT WAS THE BUSIEST WE'VE
SEEN SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC.
MORE THAN 1.7 MILLION PASSENGERS
WERE SCREENED AT TSA CHECKPOINTS
ON FRIDAY.
THE HIGHEST NUMBER WE'VE SEEN
SINCE MARCH 12th OF 2020.
THIS IS ALL PART OF A STEADY
RISE WE'RE SEEING NOW ALONGSIDE
VACCINATION NUMBERS TICKING UP.
BUT WHILE THE TOURISM INDUSTRY
IS POISED FOR A COMEBACK, IT IS
NOT WITHOUT SOME MAJOR
CHALLENGES.
NORWEGIAN CRUISE LINES IS NOW
THREATENING TO PULLS IT SHIPS
FROM FLORIDA'S PORTS AFTER
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS SIGNED A
LAW BANNING BUSINESSES FROM
REQUIRING A PROOF OF VACCINATION
FROM THEIR CUSTOMERS.
NORWEGIAN SAYS THAT LAW
CONTRADICTS FEDERAL GUIDELINES
THAT WOULD ALLOW SHIPS TO RETURN
TO U.S. WATERS AS SOON AS JULY
SO LONG AS MOST PASSENGERS AND
CREW ARE FULLY VACCINATED WHICH
IS WHAT NORWEGIAN PLANS TO DO.
THE CRUISE LINE SAYS IT IS STILL
IN CONTACT WITH GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS' OFFICE TO AVOID THIS
FIGHT AND HOPEFULLY GET BACK TO
BUSINESS.
IT'S JUST ONE MORE EXAMPLE OF
HOW UNEASY CERTAIN PLACES ARE AS
WE TRY TO GET BACK TO SOME SENSE
OF NORMAL.
>> BABY STEPS,